foreign
you only realize that when you have to
risk it
no person can become more alien than the
one you loved in the past
never do anything complicated when
something simple will serve as well
it's one of the most important secrets
of living
it was a Melancholy secret that reality
can arouse desires but never satisfy
them
the one you try to keep you lose the one
you are willing to let go with a smile
they will try to keep you
[Music]
how little we can say about women when
we're happy can't we and how much when
we're unhappy
anything you can settle with money is
cheap
life did not intend to make us perfect
whoever is perfect belongs in a museum
no Soldier outlives a thousand chances
but every Soldier believes in chance and
trusts his luck
our knowledge of life is limited to
death
[Music]
everyone saves someone at least once
just as he killed someone at least once
even though he may not know it
that is the remarkable thing about
drinking it brings people together so
quickly but between night and morning it
sets an interval again of years
yeah
to forget is the secret of Eternal youth
it grows old only through memory there's
much too little forgetting
it's no shame to be born stupid
only in dying stupid
one is old only when one no longer feels
no when one no longer loves
but that's what mankind is like they
only prize what they no longer possess
regret is the most useless thing in the
world one cannot recall anything and one
cannot rectify anything
a light doesn't shine in daylight it
shines in the dark
and whatever happens to you don't take
anything to Heart
little in the world is important for a
long time
happiness belongs to the Fearless
no matter how incredible a statement is
if it is made with sufficient certainty
it has an impact
the mind of man understands it is
impossible to live by mind alone
life is a disease and death begins at
Birth every breath every heartbeat is a
moment of dying a slight push toward the
end
foreign
the more primitive a person is the
better he considers himself
when we love each other we are Immortal
and indestructible like a heartbeat rain
and wind
extraordinary creatures you young people
are the past you hate the present you
despise and the future is a matter of
indifference
one always expects something else
human beings are a much worse poison
than schnapps or tobacco
feelings are never guilty
our damn memory is a sieve it wants to
survive and survival is Possible only
through forgetfulness
Heaven has no favorites
man is brave only when he is also afraid
modesty and conscientiousness receive
their reward only in novels
I always thought that everyone was
against the war until I discovered that
there are those who are for it
especially those who do not have to
fight in it
Faith easily relates to fanaticism that
is why so much blood has been shed in
the name of religion
don't ask about the consequences if you
want to do something otherwise you will
never do it
cheap looks confident only in what you
wear without feelings in yourself
people tend to ask too many questions in
love and once you start really wanting
to know the answers the love is gone
in a person you own only what you have
changed in him
there is something good about bad
memories they make you think that you're
happy
although a moment before that you were
convinced that you were not
the hospital alone shows what war is
it's sad when you think about life and
cynical when you see what people make of
it
I'll tell you what the meanest thing is
to draw animals into war
attachment to property restricts and
Fetters to own everything means not to
own anything
everything
why the question on which all logic all
philosophy all science has shattered up
to now
there is nothing more tiring than to be
present when a person demonstrates his
mind especially if there is no mind
a man has to have something he can put
his faith in
strange how complicated we make things
just to avoid showing what we feel
you can talk about happiness for five
minutes no more
there's nothing to say except that
you're happy
and people talk about Misfortune all
night long
those who consider themselves Fair are
particularly ruthless
when a man has seen so many dead he
cannot understand any longer why there
should be so much anguish over a single
individual
you can't know anything beforehand the
incurable can survive the healthy life
is a strange phenomenon
we have our dreams because without them
we could not bear the truth
and without love a person is a dead man
on vacation just a piece of paper with a
few dates and a random name
the invisible Storehouse in nothingness
called memory
foreign
do not need to explain anything you
always need to act with them
I don't have a future not having a
future is almost the same as not obeying
Earthly laws
anyone who can only hate or only love is
enviably primitive
we were all at once terribly alone and
alone we must see it through
courage is the fairest adornment of
Youth
those who look back too often can easily
stumble and fall
the best way to lose a woman is to show
her a kind of life that one could offer
her only for a few days
foreign